boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and we
are still on site in Brooklyn New York
we are going to be talking about
realigning technology with humanity's
best interests and we have with us max
ah so hello good to meet you just
kidding good to see you again yeah good
to see you again my man I'm super prompt
to talk about this this is one of the
most pressing issues of our time
and Max's backgrounds perfect for this
let me give you the breakdown he's a
multi award-winning storyteller poet and
filmmaker he is for years as the founder
of words that move and you've probably
seen some of his videos will link them
in the bio things like this panda is
dancing subway love and stop making
murderers famous also three years as the
head of education at the Center for
Humane technology which is what time
well spent morphed into and that's
really in this is really interesting
because max also came with an eight-year
background in social media strategy for
fortune 500 company so he was building
out these these persuasive technologies
that we see and so now he's made this
move into the Intel to the light side I
think so I'm super pumped to talk to you
this is we're gonna be talking again
about the super pressing issue that we
have as as technologies per meeting
everywhere into our world but we are
kind of like we find ourselves ethically
as kindergarteners with godlike powers
of technology to tell us about this kind
of this big history understanding of
things as we find ourselves as stewards
of the earth with these godlike powers
but we haven't really evolved our ethics
quite yet one example of this that feels
relevant that just Tristan Harris was
the leader of this movement in many ways
describes often is that he was in the
room when they decided that like a gmail
notification should an email should give
you a notification and to him that felt
like something that wow like two billion
people are all of a sudden very
frequently per day going to have their
attention diverted in a specific
direction and it didn't seem like there
was very much thought
that went into whether or not that would
be the case and so all of a sudden
technology here especially mobile
technology smartphone social media for
the first time we have a handful of
people in mostly in Silicon Valley who
are deciding how to steer the attention
of 2 billion people every day and that's
unprecedented
and that comes with tremendous
responsibility that I think it's never
been it's never been the responsibility
of corporations to think so deeply about
the ethics because there's never been so
much power or so much control
yeah when when you put it into the big
picture understanding of 2 billion
people's attention being moved based on
decisions at a corporation that that
gives us a better understanding of holy
crap
that's a huge deal and and we're
checking these devices I think on
average 150 times a day it's a two
billion people 150 times a day how much
human attention is being controlled
there and we have trouble understanding
a term like 2 billion and two billion is
I believe about as many Christians as
there are in the world yeah that's right
yeah and those are the biggest religions
Christianity Islam and now and there's a
lot of people that's a lot of and 150
times a day is being moved to so that's
a lot of collect you know you're
building up the amount of tension so
it's not just 2 billion yet seconds but
it becomes way more seconds and minutes
100 50 times a day
yeah actually be interesting to
calculate how many like days of are like
how many days years per day things like
that and be interested to see yeah how
much time is spent yeah yeah and I've
went to serious extents to to not be
manipulated by it so I have all my
notifications off on my device I have
all my apps are just deleted from my
device I so I would really hardcore cold
turkey on it and it's been extremely
helpful for me to stay really focused
and executing on what I think is most
important what's that experience been
like
fantastic yeah yeah so what a cheat did
you deleted all of your apps yeah yeah I
have like made all I have like I've like
audible okay you know like to listen to
books oh yeah and I have you know like
eat I have email in text right yeah yeah
yeah I have email text you know social
media apps yeah but have most utilities
yeah yeah that's it yeah mostly
utilities but not no social apps got and
that's been let's not get super good I'm
Way more focused and and and just all
notifications off is also very important
that way you can you look at your device
you use it as a one-way communications
tool instead of people interrupting and
you and yeah yeah especially getting
dragged into the social yeah is that
including text and email for you or
those things that's including text an
email app call that's right yeah no
notifications on my device is fantastic
nice yeah it's like the best thing ever
oh it's so good at different strokes for
different folks but I recommend
exploring that as an option ya know so
that's often in terms of and a lot of
this is about you know we do these
specific things in an effort to not be
manipulated as you put it or controlled
but at the same time it's it's almost
impossible to escape the reach because
especially about how we see the world
because even if we're not doing any of
that in our phones anytime we are
getting information from social media
that obviously is coming through a
specific filter and then even if we're
not chances are we're interact you're
interacting with me right now I'm still
using some social media so I am
influencing it's like I'm influencing
you in some ways the people in our lives
influenced us very deeply so it's almost
impossible to fully ascator and so we
really need the sort of systemic change
of help steering our focus our attention
towards the things that matter to us yes
yes so like it needs to come from there
but it's cool to hear that you've taken
that much control and are happy with it
yeah and I definitely recommend to
people it's like yeah expert like try a
week exactly try it like what just try
for a week something new and if that
works better for you then great you
should do that a think about how to end
that into your life yep yep there's a
bunch of different ways for this
realigning technology better with our
humanity that we're gonna explore in
conversation and you said one of them is
yourself to grab the the horns of the
bull and guide your own use by these um
these quant quantified self shifts in
your own life and see how it how it
affects you and then there's the
corporate and there's the government
side of things there's a bunch of that
the things that we were going to explore
max had this really interesting quote in
one of his talks that he gave he said
that we have a greater proclivity to
want to rule these worlds that we're
going to create these virtual worlds
than we do to want to like co-create and
live as a bit participate in in this one
I want you to talk about that a little
bit it's in one of the poems it's funny
I can almost never just quote in the
middle of my poems after starts the
beginning so I don't know exactly what
that quote is but it's something like
that of yeah it seems that we're so
eager to have control over these new
virtual worlds it seems that we
oftentimes are forgetting about this one
right and some of that is that it's so
much easier especially from a business
standpoint to measure success in clicks
like Scrolls actions that we can track
than it is to like measure success out
here how look how am i doing how am i
feeling how satisfied I am with the way
that the world is and the way that I am
acting in that world it's really hard to
measure that it's really hard to think
about that and it's just one of the
things that a lot of wine speak at
schools a lot of the the lung young boys
are very like spending a lot of time
gaming and like oh I gamed growing up
and I would go on like 17 hour Halo
benders one thing I tell them is that I
think if I would really check in with
how I felt the first hour I was like
this is awesome the next 17 I was in a
fit of rage just like desperately
needing to get to the next level I don't
think I was actually feeling good but
it's so much easier especially in
adolescence um to be measuring our
success based on oh like what level and
my at look this game the game has a
level like there's a clear metric
like I can control this and I can play
more and I can get further along life
doesn't work that way like life is not a
very clear like I'm at level one and
then I go to level two and then this
happens at level two like things are not
guaranteed in that way it's much more
nebulous and much more complex I think
in some ways in the digital world
because it's easier to measure of like
the action that we take and then build
whole systems around that we lose sight
of the bigger less easier to measure
much more meaningful and fulfilling
picture you know you know the scape ism
into virtual worlds is oh was something
that I think about quite a lot and I
think we are gonna want to be these
rulers of these virtual worlds more so
than participate in the world that we
have here it's when Tristana talks about
this as well when a bunch of monks came
to Google it was like a very obviously
interesting site that you see and their
biggest concern was that it's never been
easier to run from ourselves but like
the moment Oh things get a little bit
awkward or a little bit uncomfortable or
a little bit hard it's just so easy to
just sort of run run from ourselves to
the digital world because it's just a
click away just to grab away and so it's
but so much of meaning and fulfillment
and life comes from being a person
processing what we need to process and
not running away from all of our little
challenging emotions and problems not
that some escapism or entertainment
isn't also helpful and coax lining the
balance tip for everybody but certainly
it's not running away from it all the
time damn it has become so much easier
to just jump to the digital world every
time we feel a little bit uncomfortable
or uneasy like we got to face those
fears we got to face those
uncomfortability so we have to see how
they feel and process them and talk with
other humans about them because that's
how we learn and grow yeah but when we
escape out of them we never learn how to
actually grow socially emotionally yeah
okay so all right this is there's kind
of a three parts to to what the Center
for Humane tech is up to
that you want you're explaining how
technology is hijacking our minds you're
then helping build more humane tech
through different methods and you're
helping people live more intentionally
with their devices yes I mean I would
describe it as like that's certainly one
on one way of looking at it it seems
like the different pillars are the big
sort of four or five organizations that
steer so much human attention and is
there a way to successfully impact the
way that they are steering attention for
the better and to make those practices
more humane another is just general
awareness like letting people know that
we're being hijacked like trying to
steer how we tell this story towards
like that as human beings there's are
certain vulnerabilities there's like
just on talks about this and the way
that magicians are able to fool you is
it because like whether you're the
president or whether you're somebody's
like sitting on the street asking for
change there are certain ways that your
mind works and so that's why magic works
on people because there are
vulnerabilities and so since we have
these vulnerabilities and we have
technology that can exploit these
vulnerabilities can we build tech not
that exploits them but that protects us
from ways that were natural evil
naturally vulnerable
it's a spreading awareness of that
possibility and like making the average
person know how tech is affecting us and
how these vulnerabilities affect us in
different ways and then yeah and so in
governments are another pillar I don't
personally have much involvement or any
involvement within the organization but
it seems like government's going to be
involved in some way shape or form one
way or another and so advising on what
that might look like and yeah and I
won't be particularly helpful what the
answer to that question is I don't know
I'm very wary of governments but it's
that is definitely one pillar of the
organization and I wonder what ends up
becoming most effective because the
corporate has billions of attention
eyeballs so the government can be tough
to sometimes figure out how to best
regulate things like this and then
really this grassroots idea is really
strong but it's hard for people to
in the mirror at themselves and make
changes in their lives yeah I mean
that's aweso that's the awareness and
aside is where I personally am most
focused what Center for humane
technology I spend most of my time like
speaking in high schools middle schools
education conferences things like that
trying to just very plainly tell these
kids like hey look obviously technology
can be great of course there's some
things my social media that are fun
we haven't been particularly honest
about some of the ways that this is
designed that isn't really for you but
is using us not the customer but the
product and then I just show very
clearly like look this is some of the
stuff that's happening and think and in
some ways it inspires a sense of
rebellion if like hey like I don't want
to be used this way and let's the kids
think for themselves a little bit more
about do i what am i using technology or
is technology using me and I'm currently
working on a curriculum that gives like
the baseline skills of like
self-awareness emotional awareness how
to plan your day and like plan your
weeks to give these like these baseline
skills so you can notice what technology
takes away and then that also teaches a
different way of looking at social media
different ways of looking at your phone
so that's where my focus is currently
with the organization just thinking like
alright let's do some focus on the next
generation and see if we can inspire
that way and of course like our children
is a big lever and the things people
care about there's a united front so it
doesn't feel like I'm it doesn't feel
like we're it sauce purses them it's
like we all obviously want what's best
for the kids
and so that's where a lot of my
attention has been personally on on this
work I was just imagining thousands of
maxes across the high schools and middle
schools around the world giving this
talk because it's so damn important even
that little spark that you gave me it
was an it was seeing these middle and
high school students seeing themselves
in the mirror as using these products
for the addictive ways that they were
designed and then them realizing that
better that itself is so critical just
them realizing that they themselves are
are following it to addictively and that
they can be better users of the dish
technologies and you speak that little
spark under their booties is so
important for ya the most powerful
moment that accomplishes that and it's
all of us it's so much easier to make
any kind of change about the stuff in
groups it's very hard especially for
kids they're just all of a sudden be
like you know what like I'm not gonna
use an app chat anymore I'm not gonna
use Instagram anymore or I'm gonna use
them less it's like if you're the only
one it just sucks to be sitting while
everyone around you is doing that and
you just feel left out I'm so in groups
is really powerful but so when I'm in
schools the most powerful moment I think
of the talks is I say raise your hand if
you use snapchat and every hand in the
room goes up keep your hand up a few
streaks never hand just about like a
couple go down but every hand goes up
just stays up just about and then the
streak is when you keep in touch with
the person every day you get a streak
right when you send a message back and
forth within 24 hours the streak builds
so it's like we have sent two messages
three messages and more sort of like
emojis go and you start to not want to
lose that streak it's like a some people
are on a hunt multi hundred day streets
totally they go on camping trips into
the woods and they don't have service so
they leave their phones with their
friends so that they don't lose their
streets their friends will just like
take pictures of a wall and send them
back and forth to keep the street going
and say yeah I say like keep your hand
up few streaks just about every hand and
then I say keep your hand up if you like
using streaks and just about every hand
goes down in middle schools usually half
the hands go down in high school so just
about all the hands go down and so they
collectively can see like around the
room it's like oh yeah we are all doing
this thing we don't really like doing
whoa
which is like a powerful moment and then
and that's often the some of the
positive feedback I get from talks it's
like oh like they're like the cool
junior kids ended their snapchat streaks
and like this because what we talk about
there is okay like obviously this thing
has started to feel very real like hey
like are we friends if we don't keep our
streak going am i popular right popular
in high school is the whole thing if I
popular if I don't have a lot of streaks
and so these metrics that are made not
with ill intentions most of the time
just hate people like sending messages
let's gamify it yeah and that process
all of a sudden becomes very real - hey
like I really
friendships and to like just recognizing
together that like well that's silly
like obviously that shouldn't be the
case I think at least temporarily helps
rethink what that is I would love to do
more long-term follow-up of house
affecting hits but it's it's early for
for me in that way I would love to hear
more
these transitioning moments for the
youth like you just explained that how
many of you use streaks how many of you
like streaks and the hands go down how
many more of those can we create and
because then those will those help them
realize oh my gosh we don't even like
using the streaks right and then I'm
gonna stop my streaks and then what's
the next thing they're gonna do is
potentially slow down on the use of
snapchat or Instagram maybe they should
draw more make more music or to make
more videos that are educational in some
ways etc there's tons of options yeah I
mean it's it's this is hard here because
we get into that line of like how much
of this is like is reasonable to ask of
a person or a child in terms of their
own self control because that it agrees
it's important to spur these things but
also it's so hard when so much of our
lives and so much of our social lives
for a dolt like literally most of our
work like using within these devices one
way or another it's like and when
they're not designed to like protect our
human vulnerability is it's just so hard
to have any kind of real deep work
focused attitude with these devices it's
like we're fighting the Machine for that
and so especially for kids I think like
I would love for these spurred moments
to be like all it takes but it really
has to come from both sides yeah and the
another like another one is having them
in groups for a week
delete social media from their phones
mmm and like when you first bring that
up it's like yeah so you could just
delete this from your phone you don't
have to have it on there and that's
always like oh whoa whoa whoa we can't
delete social media from our phones but
I think usually the impetus that helps
is like do you really not want to know
what life is like without social media
on your phone it's like one week like
you're gonna have your whole life with
the option that's right but do you not
want to know what it feels like it's a
Google can not have it on your phone
sort of create it like a challenge
that's a challenge yeah it's like to
turn turn it off for a week and see what
the difference is like and maybe write
about what the difference is like sure
yeah that's a good action yes that's a
good exercise make a video about what it
was like and put that onto YouTube and
Instagram afterwards and put it on
snapchat I wanna I want to want to move
into young we were we started talking
about this earlier with how there is a
zero-sum game going on with with the
attention economy that there is only 16
hours of waking attention per human per
day spent 8 an hour sleeping and then
there's about 7 point 7 billion people
on the planet so there's somewhere
around a hundred and twenty plus billion
hours of collective human attention as a
cake on the planet and then the YouTube
algorithms and Facebook algorithms etc
are all and these Streak designs in
snapchat they're all trying to keep you
more tied on two screens because their
business models are tied with making
money for their shareholders and for
their company based on advertising
revenue and so this sort of attention
economy plus the business models of time
and money being intertwined rather than
designing technology to help humanity
thrive is one of the biggest issues I
believe so I believe that's right at the
center of it
the most convincing frame of this that
I've heard is that like the moment so
auto-playing videos as an example the
moment someone like YouTube figures out
hey if we autoplay videos we get about
10% more attention like okay great like
that works let's do that and so when I
was working for a social media startup
we certainly found that when you
autoplay videos like that grabs more
attention and so if that works and all
of a sudden someone like YouTube
implements that everyone else has to
look at that 0font some cake and say hey
like youtube just deployed this new
trick that works and it takes 10% more
attention they're eating my market share
like I need more of that person's time I
can't look at you as a human being
with hopes and dreams and that
and it's like I that's you're stealing
my time I need that time back so then
Facebook has to autoplay videos in their
newsfeed and then you know Netflix also
a lot like everyone starts to fight in
this same game for how do we grab as
much attention as possible Tristana
talks about it it's reaching down the
brainstem and grabbing as much tension
as we possibly can and say that's and I
think we've like it's you know I don't
believe that Facebook right now has
designed an algorithm that is perfectly
maximized to steal as much attention as
possible I don't think they're doing
that anymore I think they have taken a
step back but should it turn out that
the best thing for people is to like you
know what like turns out spending
seventy five percent less time on
Facebook is like is what makes people
feel most alive and thriving and happy
can they really make changes like that
in the business model that we have right
now the answer is no and so that this is
this is a crucial point so it's like if
we measure humans thriving and human
well-being and flourishing across so
many different facets of finding meaning
in life's me building really strong
relationships with with our families and
our friends and we see that we the more
that the the business models must change
on the social media companies in order
for the flourishing to actually happen
so the the time that we get sucked away
into social is taking us away from
creative endeavoring and meaning and so
many other crucial things so then there
has to be a business model shift there
has to be a shift towards oh and then I
don't know if a Facebook or Instagram or
Google will ever be able to really do
that I don't talk about you you've
talked about it and I've gotten really
inspired about this potential idea for
shift as well is that we don't need to
see ads we don't need to have time on
screen be the best measure for their
revenue it can actually be based on me
paying five dollars a month or 10
dollars someone to use these services to
not only not see ads but also for
to build out functionalities that enable
me to say I only want to use this for X
amount of minutes I want my data I want
my facebook connection network graph and
I want to see how often I'm connecting
and talking to people in a way that is
visualized in a beautiful way sure and
so yeah visualizing that could be part
of it I could see that but yeah the key
thing to think about is that you're not
paying for like oh so I don't see ads
anymore like it's like sure yes but what
you're really paying for is for these
algorithms to put you first
it's nice to actually think about your
life think about what is like how do I
live for me how do I live the way that I
want to live Joe Edelman who helped
coined time well spent with Tristan like
really believes the answer is in human
values and helping people live by their
values talks about how oftentimes we get
to our goals and then we think like oh
like well I'm here and now what I didn't
feel as good as I thought I did but if
we like oh like I really wanted to show
up this into this interview with
presence and with like thoughtfulness
and if I show up that way then I feel
good about showing up that way and so
Joe dreams of a world where these
algorithms are helping people discover
and unlock what our values are the ways
that we feel good about how we showed up
regardless of outcome regardless of what
other people are doing it with us and
helping us live that way more often and
more freely and with more options but so
yeah I would absolutely pay for services
that are really helping me do that and
this is the challenge because Facebook
Google have the data to do that well
right now just about no one else does
and so like I would love for the next
wave to be thinking this way too it's
like if you're not doing it well it's
just kind of annoying yeah so it's like
it needs to happen well and I would
absolutely pay for services that are
really helping me be a better me in a
way that I decide yeah me too and we see
tons of people paying upwards of you
know 50 bucks a month for different
subscriptions to things like premiere
which
gives you video editing abilities you
know Adobe's Creative Suite or you know
MailChimp for managing your mail lists
you know different people people are
paying you Todd the in the tens of
dollars a month it would be easy if if
you if the large Giants made that much
money off their two billion users that a
billion of them would pay them ten bucks
a month ten billion dollars a month
could get you the best engineers and
designers to maximize the thriving of
the values of the of each individual
there's I think there's a business model
there it also any quality question that
happens like this is not perfect like
there's some people can't afford those
right but like but if this thing that
I'm talking about that helps me be a
better happier and more fulfilled
version of me I also like all of the
money that I give to charity every year
like that feels like a heck of a place
to give is to help people who can't
afford it be better versions of
themselves like in such an integrated
way so then there's a there's a
charitable aspect of it that's a good
charity you're like all right I mean
even like a one-for-one model type thing
right of like of being it I would
happily it's like pay just in my like as
I'm paying for that service or someone
who can't afford yeah okay max let's
talk about the actual design of the tech
we've been talking about it quite a bit
but I want to specifically talk about
things like the the the we're finding
ourselves more and more in echo chambers
and that's been the worst I think one of
the worst things is that we're no longer
even having a civil discourse with
people that think differently than we do
about hey you know I have deep empathy
for you I want to know how you got to
where you got in your life what stimuli
did you absorb to get where you are now
it's that I never ever see opposing
viewpoints ever in my conversations with
other people in my news feeds because
I'm constantly fueled into staying in a
silo of information and that's tribal
izing us in much more serious ways and
even further is that
when you look things up sometimes you
can see different results based on where
you're located based on your likes so
this is a nuanced and challenging
because I think because we ought were
actually seeing we're seeing I believe
on average or more viewpoints of like
things that we didn't believe yet but
we're seeing them for the most part in
ways that like that cement the thing
that we already do believe like I you
know it's very easy to see the online
right now the people who are saying the
ridiculous outrageous thing that is so
infuriating and like I'm exposed to that
viewpoint but I'm being exposed to the
viewpoints that like piss me off I'm
like how could they think this and like
I think further isolate me into my side
and in some ways it feels like we're in
like your each in our own echo chamber
of like as we consume more and more
information through screens and zeyneb
to fetch key talks about this really
beautifully about how when she was
researching the Donald Trump rallies she
would she would watch over 1/2 the
videos on YouTube about Donald Trump and
wrap those rallies and then she would be
pushed towards more and more videos
about white about white supremacy it's
not the same thing white supremacy and
being a teleprompter trump supporter are
not the same thing but in the YouTube
algorithm there was just a natural push
towards the more extreme view of
something that kind of fits within that
category and then with Bernie Sanders
videos it was the same for towards the
conspiracy left and this isn't just
politics it's like this is the algorithm
figuring out human behavior and pushing
us more extreme versions of what we're
likely to believe you look for
vegetarian videos you're pushed towards
veganism it's like you're never hardcore
enough for YouTube you never hardcore
enough for this whole internet system
and so like it becomes very hard to
engage with people when whatever we're
prone are likely to believe were pushed
towards more extreme versions of that
and then anyone who doesn't believe that
our way that the world is melting is the
way the world is melting it's like oh
they just don't get it how do how do
they not get it I can't really like you
just don't see you just don't know you
don't see what I see you don't know what
I know and it's hard to like it's hard
to relate to that person because we're
all being pushed constantly towards the
extremes of our ideas and it's a bit
like and there's one other thing that
you
and filter bubbles and there's one other
thing I wanted to clarify Oh search like
within search like yet Google patches
things very quickly like I've like I
think there's much less of I search one
thing you search another thing than
there was in the past but it's very very
hard in like-new of news event happens
like live scenario something is going on
right now you have lots of people
searching right now Google has no time
to like with all of the things that are
happening in different areas of the
world that are being searched heavily
how could one like possibly like just
patch all of the different
misinformation all of the different like
chaos that's happening in that moment of
like a new search term that didn't have
any context with it before so you've got
that like the speed problem of we have
this urge we have this like something's
happening I want to know what do we
actually learn when we're following
these things live like there's very like
it's more just entertainment we're like
oh my god something's happening and I'm
watching we learned very little from
like being the sparse bits of
information we're picking up but there
are lots of people who are checking that
out and tons of misinformation happens
over Google and over all the platforms I
think that way in the very fast and the
very fast events and like these are not
easy problems to solve like at all like
how do you fix that I don't know I don't
know how you fix that but if I were
running Google I would have gigantic
teams who are dedicated to just that and
it feels like much less of the priority
than so many other things that are
involved with growth and profit Mac yeah
yeah yeah man this it's a so keeping the
company sustaining with profit but also
figuring out how to get that profit most
effectively with balancing the human
flourishing and human values oh it's a
yeah it's such a super time and I like I
really so apples my one like I really
hope Apple can step up for us but it
seems to most of I think something like
90% of apples revenue comes from
hardware and
from like my ads yeah and so and to be
able like to have them be a gatekeeper
for us so that companies that are doing
like to really be thinking hey like how
helpful for you is like seeing news the
moment it happens like how is that
serving you like is and maybe it is but
like can you go through some kind of
process to really think about whether
that's the case and then if that isn't
the case then like maybe the apps that
do that or the systems that do that
aren't pinging you all the time but are
kind of relegated within the app store
or relegated within your phone and other
things that are serving you better based
on the way you decide not like one
person decides from here this is what a
good life is and go like I do believe we
need that kind of choice and ability to
figure it out for ourselves but can
someone like Apple help us find that and
help protect us from the things that we
might like that our more impulsive
selves might very often push us towards
and this is a lot of this is also about
the young people that can build the next
versions of the hardware and software
and the apps and the business models
that they get to creatively brainstorm
and figure out what's the next best way
to build that maximises flourishing and
I hope so the psychometric side of
things is very crazy too that you are
better known now by your 300 Facebook
Likes than you then your spouse knows
you or even with 10 likes better than
your coworker knows you and so that sort
of footprint is why don't we have access
to these footprints these cycle metrics
why can't I see how I'm being profiled
on the Internet these are ways that we
can better understand ourselves through
getting access to the data that we
actually create but that is being used
to sell us ads and places in a buckets
the psychometric side of things is what
are your thoughts on cycle yeah it's
interested there's there's that
Kaczynski study that that I think
actually ended up being fed into a lot
of the Cambridge analytical stuff I
don't know that much about to be honest
but I it did seem like in that study
from just like page likes these were
like you like Metallica whatever like
those type of likes not the literal
things you press like on and your
feed and if you think about what
Facebook actually has on you it's
everything you've ever clicked on
scrolled through hovered over like like
share comment how long you spent sucking
your ex boyfriends and girlfriends on
Instagram and on Facebook like all of
that data is collected by Facebook and
we don't have that and Kaczynski didn't
have that but with just page likes he
was able to move certain calls about us
better than we knew ourselves and so
like that is that is wild and actually I
love what you've all you've all Harare
talked about about this where he talked
about how when he's gay and when he came
out of the closet he spent the next six
months looking back and thinking like
how did I not know this thing about like
this obvious thing about myself like how
did I not realize that he talks about
how when you're a baby like your mom
knows you better than you know yourself
and then you get to know yourself better
than your mom knows you but now we're
kind of in this race to know ourselves
better than technology knows us and
that's a tough race yeah and one of the
things that he he talks about as well
he's like it feels like any sort of out
like an eye tracking software could have
probably given me a pretty reasonable
probability like that I was my eyes were
going to shirtless men faster than
shirtless women um I'm like what would
it have been like for a for to get a
notification one day saying hey there's
an 85 percent probability that like but
you might be gay like just wanted to let
you know what that world look like and
also what would it look like for Coke to
be serving him shirtless men ads because
they knew and Pepsi be serving him
Charlotte so women ads and him just not
really should be sure why he liked coke
a little bit better than he liked Pepsi
and so he talked about this race to know
ourselves and so as an individual one of
the best things we can do to combat this
it's like really get to know our
triggers get to know who we are and it's
you know it's a losing battle in some
ways because this stuff knows so much
about us and it's going so fast but I do
think it's in it's meaningful and
important work in my own life anyway to
try and get to know like what's going on
on the inside because others are trying
to figure that out yeah what is your
full divine potential here on earth how
can you best understand thyself but you
also give these beauty examples of
technical
helping us understand ourselves and that
was really interesting because there's
so much potential for that sure yeah and
that's the good side of tech yeah I
guess I mean what would it look like if
like I mean I just I can't even real I
don't know I don't know what it would
look like for Facebook to be using all
that data to like steer me in a
direction that I choose towards a
specific outcome or towards a specific
way of being or value set that I have
that it's helped me figure out or that
I've figured out and the complex
questions that come with these sort of
ideas like it is not perfect by any
means but it feels to me so obviously
better than what exists now and whoever
has access to the large data set of
biometrics on our bodies and be able to
leverage things like heart rate or pupil
dilation or whatnot whatnot with the
front-facing cameras that that also
makes a tremendous difference on
hopefully their their benevolence a
benevolent technology hopefully it's
there for the betterment of our us to
figure out so it needs to be but a
minute yeah you're right and it's scary
because who do you trust and like who
are gonna be a hopefully benevolent
overlords of who is running these and
who's collecting these data and that's
why like as you've mentioned here like
these advertising models are not really
in our favor as we speed in that
direction so we really need to set up
systems so that the people collecting
these data even have the opportunity to
be benevolent because in this system
they do not there's a big push for
opening up the data silos and letting
data flow better so I think one of the
first steps is going to be I think the
decentralization of the data and
enabling the data to flow and then when
that sort of potentially like encrypted
anonymized data can flow more easily
then the then also simultaneously
figuring out the business model side of
things on potentially having people like
us pay 10 20 30 whatever bucks a month
again access to them helping make the
algorithms for our own flourishing those
things kind of smell
together would make it more so okay now
we're collecting the new biometric data
again encrypted and decentralized
anonymously and then when we are we're
gathering that now we're incentivized
also just like all the other big data
giants are is to not keep that data
siloed it's to provide it with a maximal
level of flourishing for you it's gonna
take us a while to get there but there's
not really that much time to get that we
need leadership to stand up and say that
you know these if the big if Facebook
Apple Google Amazon if they if they
intend sent and Alibaba if these big
Giants across China in the United States
if they kind of if they kind of opened
up by do if they opened up their their
their hearts to want this faster and
they created a coalition like the United
Nations potentially the United
technology companies that they could
make this change as like a first
principle pillar of their organizations
it would just again and be very
difficult on the revenue side of things
where things would go from there but
doing it all together could be a good
way to do it rather than having like
seven of them looking at one that's
trying to do it and be like we're not
going to do that we need to make money
so it's I mean it's certainly it's set a
lot in there there's certainly it's it's
hard to just make that change uh
switchover I also don't think it's clear
for many what that change really is or
what that change really looks like it's
like definitely in this at the core
thinking about people differently but
also like if we a lot of people that we
need to break up Facebook need to break
up these big companies I mean right now
at least we know where to look you know
like I think decentralizing and
encrypting all of this data and
information like also in theory it's
like rate can start to see how that
creates a better world but also just
like the same problems we have but now
everywhere like feels even more chaotic
to me too so it's it's really it's it's
challenging to think about like can we
actually saw
what's at the root of these problems of
thinking about people differently rather
than looking at it as okay let's just
let's decentralize that information and
then like Facebook isn't the only one
who has it so everybody has it and it's
like it's tough to even know where to
look or where to go and I it's we're
honestly we're like knit we're thinking
now further ahead and then I can kind of
see clearly to how that's gonna look
when it when it if or when it does all
break away that way but like I think the
key here is about genuinely thinking
about like the incentive model the
incentive structures and like aligning
our goals with the goals of what people
are creating to be able to really push
us in a direction that's gonna feel good
because like just being like what just
changing like the way the data is
distributed or things like that don't
necessarily solve the the core problems
yeah I love how much time you've spent
on this and okay let's let's talk about
kids and children use your going around
and speaking and you're getting kids to
really realize like oh [ __ ] you know we
we really don't like the street feature
we really don't we don't we haven't
taken a week away from social media to
see what that feels like there's more
and more research that's coming out
about about depression about anxiety
about suicide rates about the fear of
missing out about what it's like if
you've got to take millions of photos of
your own face throughout throughout your
life and try and find the best ones that
if you're so distracted that you're
checking it so of the phone so often
when are you focused on your own
creative endeavor and focused on gaining
empathy and social skills so this is a
serious effect for children growing up
absolutely and it's into the research
side of this is very hot it's very
challenging and I was an important point
because in my experience the people
especially at Facebook and at some of
these bigger companies are trying to be
very research driven and very
data-driven and some of the research
being like look depression is
skyrocketing like isn't particularly
robust like it's definitely a thing to
look out for and pay attention to but
I'm
sure that it's like convincing but that
I mean like that said I mean I do
believe that if we were able to have
more serious and robust research I think
we would absolutely especially with
Instagram finds like all the self
comparison leading to mental health
issues and depression and things like
that but and also that said like in
terms of looking at the research here
what's gonna actually happen for any
kind of longitudinal study you're
looking at you have okay let's say we're
trying to go three years three years
they have a child going from one stage
of development to another by three years
you have a completely different tack
ecosystem things are working in a
totally new way and so you have to
challenge the effects between those two
things just it's gonna be really hard
just like period to find any kind of
reliable research about anything in this
field which is really tough it's like a
tough place to where we can points to be
able to point directly to like look like
this is a reason this is how this is
affecting us but absolutely like it
feels so obvious to me some of the
things that we're losing that we need to
think about this more cautiously and
more skeptically my advice to schools is
to like like we had for awhile the ethos
was like great like an iPad in every
hand like perfect like now we have these
new tools this new innovative technology
in the classroom all the beautiful
example is how wonderful and yes there
are some beautiful advantages but we
just didn't really think about what we
were losing as we were putting that in
the classroom and so I think a much
better attitude is like okay let's look
and assume that 99% of the new EDX
that's coming in like doesn't actually
help or isn't really gonna be effective
isn't gonna create new problems to
introduce this environment let's look at
it as a skeptic and really be like
proved to me like show me that this
actually really learns it really helps
kids learns really helps improve and use
that skeptical eye um the way I see it
we have an opportunity for like a seven
hour period during the day to cheat
children focus patience and how to be
without their devices with exceptions
like of course with exceptions there's
certain special ed programs that have
been proven to be really effective using
technology like certain vulnerable
populations like trans students like I
found social media to be a really
positive
source of support and of course I should
be like some classes and some things we
really do use the phones and do use do
you use tech that way
but it feels like the standard should be
like that's the exception and not the
rule and like are we really at risk of
kids not knowing how to use these
devices or not as soon as they get out
of school being totally on them all the
time it's like can we can we use that
period in school to teach this thing
that they really otherwise might not
understand or learn yep laughing at your
deep breath yeah max likes this TARDIS
talks by having deep breaths yeah feel
the humanity and this is a really
important time to take a deep breath
because we're talking about children and
children are though to Future Leaders
and for us to see them making duck faces
at at snapchat I mean we knew stupids
you know this was all some stupid stuff
as kids too I don't know it does the
dumb thing I do think we're in a
category shift of what this is we do
dumb things to your that's not the same
not the same we don't have we didn't
carry around our TVs for hours a day
yeah we did yeah
have to go into them to talk to our
friends yeah that's right that's right
lack of eye contact and this 72% of
teens think they're being manipulated by
technology that's a really good one that
just on set at the Salesforce thing yeah
wonder where that's from yeah so you
said that at the Dreamforce talk that he
gave a couple months ago so you we've
been talking about some of the some of
the tools that are that are being built
I want us to really highlight some of
these tools I personally have been using
like Facebook newsfeed Eradicator on
desktop so you don't even see your
Facebook newsfeed like that a lot that's
a good one so is a Stanford's habit lab
is really good late they literally
interrupt you all the time yeah they'll
they'll yeah you're you like typing
reddit or Facebook or Instagram whatever
and they'll just be like you
like what's your objective how many
minutes do you even want to spend on
here should we just close this tab right
now and it's like yeah actually I didn't
want to do this [ __ ] huh and sometimes
you're like you actually need to send a
message to someone so I only want to
mint it on here and then you click that
and then it literally after your you it
like logs after 60 seconds there's a
countdown and it closes the tab it's
like nope you're done well I'm so it's
interesting things like that that again
we're trying to quantify our own habits
using these things so yeah tell us about
some of the ways that you know that
you're that you're seeing these ethical
tech breakthroughs happen so yeah right
now it's like a lot of patchwork right
it's a lot of things like that that
people are actually yeah like things
like have it lab are that are doing and
that's cool to hear that's been a factor
for you and a lot of this is about
finding what does work for you but yet
turning off all notifications aren't
from a human being trying to reach you
is one that we recommend if you want to
go all the way into turning off all
notifications sounds like that's been
cool too basically your time but the
ones were like Facebook saying like oh
you have 30 new notifications and it's
like trying to really win Twitter's like
you have five new notifications trying
to really like you you know this person
liked your photo even or happy holidays
from tinder you haven't play candy crush
in a while like all of the hosts get off
they're not those notifications gosh
those are so little low hanging fruit
those are so manipulative out of the two
billion people that use the smartphone
technologies what percentage of them
still have those low hanging fruit
enabled because that's a really good
question because that if we could just
knock that one out of the park for you
like it's a question that only the
company knows there's the answer to
they're the ones who have that day I bet
it's over 50% I just have a feeling
think most people just don't even know
to switch and yes they're like her that
you can do that or like the default is
what most people do yeah um India which
is that's a big part of the issue
Gaja just it sounds to me when you say
the words you know you know candy crush
since you haven't played for a while or
tenders like come get your holiday date
or whatever to me it makes my whole body
feel
uncomfortable makes me feel so bad
because we can't be designing technology
that way you know these shows even
though these shows are never pay walled
completely free we never expect you to
want to watch you watch how you prefer
to watch if you want to watch all our
great if you want to watch 30 and 30
great do your thing with it we're not
gonna send you messages to say oh you
haven't learned about biotech in a while
come learn about biotech we'd rather ask
you a question like you know about your
life like hey what are you most
interested in learning about right now
oh you're interested in biotech okay
great we can do that or there's you know
a bunch of other news sources that
actually talk about biotech needs as
well so we want to push you into where
you're most interested in yeah yeah and
if in your life learning is what you
want to focus on it this Minds like
those old bill there's lots of ways yes
I'm thinking about this thing going on
yes yes um but I like learning
notification yeah makes you put that in
your whole body
I like that I like that it does that I
forgot I was gonna say yeah the defaults
in general I think are what most people
have on and that's not great yeah and
then how about um how about your work
you know you you you're going out and
speaking to middle and high schools
you're also other parts of your team
we're also doing work with the the
corporate and in government side of
things what are you finding to be in a
good way that they're that they're
transitioning into ethical tech that
companies are that and go from
governments alright
I'm just so ignorant the government side
they don't even want to don't even want
us to companies Tom yeah the waste
companies are transitioning its
unfortunately it feels a lot like mostly
at this moment and like I think Facebook
has absolutely taken steps like I think
they genuinely care but it often feels
like they're mostly running a PR machine
with a lot of this like new problem and
like we're handling or han't like trying
it feels like they care more about the
PR than solving the issue and that
makes me sad um but it's uh and actually
that's what I was gonna say about the
dark patterns is that when I turned off
my facebook notifications like Facebook
up progressively more more desperate of
like to the point of just sending me a
text message I'm just like being like
like hey like this person like like what
it was it was like I was tagged in a
post you know how sometimes on Facebook
people just like tagged 15 people and I
was tagged in one and I was getting
texts of all the comments of this post
and if you turn that off yeah well sure
like I mean there's its own separating
every I think I just blocked the number
I just got frustrated got angry like
they're still going after me yeah how do
you shift towards more ethical tech and
a lot of this is aligning the business
model really thinking deeply and
carefully about what it is that the
people using your product are there for
and making sure that you're not that you
care more about what they're there for
than what you're there for those things
have to be aligned and how are you
helping it's just putting the person
really first and at the center of this
it's so easy to think what we do more
good than bad like so we do more good
than bad so it's okay will tolerate some
of these like you know we can do this
little thing everybody's doing this
thing we'll do this little thing it's so
easy to think that way it's much harder
to really like to be like to respect
somebody's time and attention more than
you like yeah more than you might want
to encroach that might be kind of good
for you but really yeah the most respect
over someone's time and attention
that's such a good way to put it and
that's kind of what we were talking
about a moment ago is thinking about
what you're building and realizing that
your primary goal is to put yourself out
there with your content but you want to
respect other people's attention you
want to make yourself known but you
don't want to forcibly real people in
it's not no it's not it's not
yeah principle to roll off of yeah okay
I want to talk about so max you'll see
is within with the links below
Max's use of poetry in a rhythm and a
rhyme in the way that he disseminates
ethical technology and a bunch of other
really interesting
video through video as well tell us
about how you latched onto onto that and
and alright and we'd love to do a little
little like freestyle yeah we'll see
what happens yeah but for me I heard
this poet named Q performing a friend's
at a friend's living room actually and I
was just really moved I was a bad time
in the tech world in the storytelling
world and I was really surprised at how
much I remembered of the Reimann rhythm
and just like how much it stuck with me
and on the way home I started writing in
the first two lines of what I wrote
happened to rhyme and I was like okay
let's give this a shot and I've come to
realize that I think one of the big
draws for me was yeah that rhyme and
rhythm just like help us listen in a way
that we would not ordinarily and in a
distracted ATD world it seems like a
very powerful tool to get a message like
in its entirety from where it comes from
like or where it comes from directly to
where it needs to go
and so rhymin rhythm have been helpful
to me in that way and that is like I
think got at my core like I'm trying to
and trying I like my found sometimes I
found I found it like I found a thing
and I need to show you this thing and I
want you to see this thing the way I see
this thing and rhyme and rhythm have
been a powerful tool to help me do that
yeah there's something also so you know
you started getting at this like we got
to figure out new artistic and creative
strategies to get content out to people
like through rhyme and rhythm that can
that can that can that can turn people's
heads to be like whoa that's different
than what the majority of things I'm
saying maybe I should look over here a
little bit longer and that's how we can
potentially find these new paths of
engaging with people in ways that are
exciting and new and yeah I like to do
that but I mean it-it's appreciated and
thank you for those kind words about my
work I appreciate you in that and
appreciate you saying that and it's for
me I would love to see a system where
it's like what what content is not a
human need right like what do you like
what are you looking for
in this moment what are you looking for
how are you looking to be and if my work
can help that great have that rise to
the top if other stuff can help that
great have that rise to the top
but have a different content
distribution system that's not just
about what grabs attention the most
effectively but it's about how am i
helping you in some way shape or form
with whatever you're like looking for or
trying to be in this moment yeah yes so
you know you know we're all little tiny
specks so we should learn how to better
use our tech you know again yeah it's
like there's a poet now who's a poet now
yes sir yeah yeah I want I want everyone
to also when when you go and check out
some of the videos below with this Panda
is dancing the video there's this really
interesting moment about the realization
that if tech helped make us more human
that we would we would we would
potentially get that flower that we need
to give to someone really cool that we
meet on the streets and just a click of
a button that in subway love that you
would realize that the people standing
next to you on the subway is everyone's
just engrossed in their own worlds that
those might be our potential future
lover or our future business partner or
someone that's a really good friend
potentially of ours and it's not making
murderers famous you realize that you
are we need to stop putting the names of
the people that are committing the
atrocities anywhere period and that only
only when you're still trying to find
them but besides that there's no point
and and that way there's no increase in
clout for more people to follow a
phenomenon that similar to that so I
want you guys to all check out those
videos max what's a core driving
principle of yours to try and tell the
truth to try and
I try to tell the truth try be impactful
- yeah - no changes all the time but
like that right now honesty and impact
are very much central math and if you
could rebuild civilization from scratch
how would you design it Wow I mean
that's what we're kind of that's what
we're talking about so this whole thing
has been about
and I would be designing it so that I
think I mean I wouldn't design it myself
I would be trying to gather people who
have thought deeply about what makes
living meaningfully what's lives a
meaningful life and how I would think of
trying to have everybody work together
to create those things I think in some
ways like capitalism naturally has
encouraged a lot of positive behaviors
for a long time negative as well it's
like some systems just tend to work to
create meaningful society and
capitalism's got us a long way it's got
its problems but it's gone it's a long
way I'm grateful that I don't have to
rebuild society and civilization just
crash it's too much pressure have an
answer I don't know um yeah I don't know
but I know some of the things to think
about and that's what we've been talking
about yeah and do you think this is a
simulation um how do you define a
simulation oh you would define one ah
totally well but now I want to know what
you mean by simulation is this a base
reality or is this a simulation like in
simulation theory ah
I think they're like infinite
possibilities of what reality is an
infinite but I believe in a multiverse
mm-hmm I believe from what I understand
of that of that theory but I think
and whether it look whether or not it's
a simulation it seems like it doesn't
matter like we're here we're now or
wherever you are you're there you're now
and like that last moment it's gone but
now we're in a new moment vision that
were in a new moment ago and yeah that's
right that's where I'm at right now but
it's funny I'm very aware of the cameras
of like I don't have I don't know like
I've just pass stuff we've been talking
about I know a lot about I don't know if
we're in a simulation I don't know
exactly what the nature of reality is
I'm trying to figure it out you're a
video game character that is working on
helping this civilization evolved on
this rock orbiting this star figuring
out how to help them make ethical tech
at this important transition area moment
figuring out how to make like the most
of our lives and figure out how to see
how much [ __ ] beauty there is and
live that way and help each other and
tolerate each other yeah those are
things I'm trying to do perfect segue
into the last question what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world now we get to be here that we get
to live and get to exist that we get to
yeah the that of all the like that there
is anything that there that this is that
like all of it that it is it's just
remarkably beautiful yeah yeah max this
has been super enlightening thank you
for joining us on the show thank really
appreciate it
everyone watching go and check out Max's
work in the bio below go and check out
those links also let us know your
thoughts in the comments below about the
episode and some of the ethical tech
conversation that we've been having go
and try these little quantified self
experiments and see how you behave
differently in the world when you turn
off certain sets of notifications or
delete apps and just see how you behave
differently and measure that better
about ourselves and we help help us out
help out help out the Center for humane
technology
the links below also help out simulation
links below we'd love to continue doing
cool things like coming on site and
talking to great leaders like max and go
and build the future everyone manifest
your destiny into the world go build go
create we love you so much and dose up
on love take care see you soon that's it
that's it
cool that's how we do thanks